cameras may have caught zendaya falling
but she's the one having the last laugh
during a recent trip to rome the 25 year
old euphoria star slipped and nearly
wiped out walking from her car up a
flight of stairs but thankfully was
caught by her security detail before
hitting the ground i just feel very
lucky
only zendaya could make falling look
that graceful this is awesome let's run
that back one more time shall we
anyway the internet quickly did what the
internet does and the moment was turned
into a million and one different memes i
don't know how excited people would be
to just jump on board but zendaya she's
in on the joke
they got me they got me on monday the
actress shared snaps mid-tumble
alongside the caption i can't stop
laughing did they really have to take a
video of me tripping no but really
zendaya couldn't stop laughing
they got me in another post zendaya
commented on her ensemble a black dress
with matching pumps writing i was trying
to be cute today
zendaya is the one at serving looks
she's the one to go for for tips of
course when zendaya isn't falling
upstairs she can be found out with her
boyfriend tom holland you heard it here
on etv
last week the two were snapped looking
chic in new york city leaving their
hotel hand-in-hand
i mean dude i'm just as excited of
course the two met while filming
spider-man homecoming back in 2017. it's
just the beginning of this really
adorable romance that we're watching
kind of bloom on camera but will the
love birds ever team up on screen again
when e.t chatted with the actress about
euphoria she teased the idea of tom
making a cameo listen we talked about it
you know because uh
um he supported me through the whole the
whole season and you know we we joke
about like just spitting them into the
background
it was an easter egg see if someone can
can spot him and she hinted at what fans
can expect from sunday's big season two
finale there's a dark place that hits
right in the middle of the season that
was painful i think for everyone
involved in making it i know it was hard
for me
um and i think once we got to that point
we were like we can't leave her here
this can't be the end of her story there
has to be some hope
um at the end of this some light at the
end of the tunnel you know i think
beautiful at the end of all this pain
and i think that that's what we really
need i think this world world needs is a
little bit of hope in a lot of ways you
know so if you can hold on to that if
you can
you know bear with her if you can love
her through those those painful moments
and still root for her maybe there's
some hope at the end
you